ladies and gentlemen professor Potts I'm  an artist the greatest puppeteer of his  generation  [Applause]  it seems some volker getting squeamish  around here  stop strolling women all that nonsense  happy stoning day you have to stay on  the straight and sober can you do that  where's baby punch where is she I salute  her gallery one place she wound up in  another what's not is done suppose we  just move on with our lives that's the  way to do it they've come to report a  crime right excellent my dear wife and  tiny baby aren't missing do you remember  what happened to you  [Applause]  [Music]  does that look punchy guy always win you  won't be winning any more the greatest  Joe is what the critics say  [Music]  that's the way to do it  you